supposing that these clinics arise in
the next 10 years or so where people
will be able to have
psychedelic enhanced uh couples therapy
let's see what happens if we can just
go into this place together put our
shared values on the table talk to the
therapist about what we want to
accomplish learn about the effects of
this drug recognize that it will put us
into a different state of mind for a
while the effects of the drug won't be
permanent but while we're in that
altered state of mind maybe we'll be
able to kind of recapture rekindle or
explore some things together that just
because of the pattern that we're in
we aren't able to really do by our own
volition and see what happens some of
the people who have been in these trials
recently say
i look at my partner like when we first
met again and for some people
having the direct influence of a drug to
kind of wipe out some of their patterned
ways of thinking and allow them to see
what's right in front of them with new
eyes does allow them to kind of remember
and re-experience why it is that they
value the relationship in the first
place and to me that doesn't seem
inauthentic that just seems like
we can get ourselves into inauthentic
patterns by
falling into habits that aren't good for
us
what is love
that's a good question i've spent a lot
of time thinking about it and obviously
so have a lot of other people in a lot
of different
disciplines and using different lenses
um most of us i think probably start to
think about love outside of our own
experiences through art and literature
and maybe philosophy
more recently scientists have taken an
interest in love and they're starting to
figure out what's
going on in our brains when we at least
report subjectively that we feel that
we're in love and they start to try to
triangulate in and see
neurochemically what's happening um so i
end up adopting a view that tries to
integrate all of these different
perspectives so i think of love as
kind of a bio psychosocial phenomenon
it's something that
feels a certain way so there are
subjective components to it and if you
report that you're in love and i report
that i'm in love we're kind of comparing
notes and trying to see is what you're
feeling the same thing is what i'm
feeling
and to do that we'll often refer to
tropes and scripts and concepts in the
culture so you might say well it feels
like that thing that's represented in
that movie or when i read this poem by
so and so it really makes me feel like
that's what i'm feeling
and that's one of the ways in which we
compare notes is through cultural
artifacts
and then there's also stuff going on in
our brains as i suggested so
at the at the very least you know love
is scaffolded on top of things that are
related to our our nature as a sexually
reproducing species so
the reason why we're drawn toward at
least some people in this passionate way
and we want to
meld with them has got to be related to
the fact that we reproduce
sexually and so we're going to have to
have mating partners and
love is wrapped up in that there's some
some theories that suggest love has kind
of different phases or stages so
there's a set of brain systems that are
oriented around
uh lust or libido which is just to drive
us toward
a potentially range of mating partners
there's attraction which narrows our
focus in on a smaller
number of people maybe one in particular
and then attachment which is this
long lasting kind of pair bond that
exists in a lot of different mammal
species and in ours
and that's more if toward childbearing
potentially your long-term relationships
so how that plays out in a given
cultural or historical context well that
depends on you know
accidents of history and um you know
prevailing concepts and ideas so love
just situ
sits at the interface of these kind of
biological subjective experiential
psychological aspects and the wider
social historical context that's
that's the best i can say of what love
is i've been
fascinated this year thinking about the
difference between the reductionist
standpoint of how our emotions are
created
whatever the particular combination of
chemicals or neurotransmitters that have
to fire to make it happen
and the phenomenological experience of
what it feels like to be in love
because it doesn't just feel like a
combination of chemicals it feels like
some sort of blessing or curse bestowed
on you by a higher power right
and i think it justifies a lot spending
time thinking about evolutionary
psychology this year
um justifies a lot of why religion came
about
this sort of narrative personified of
what it is that is happening so it
doesn't just feel like a combination of
chemicals
it feels so powerful
yeah i mean so because we have to make
to reproduce it makes sense that just
like our hunger drive is very strong so
as our drive to be close to certain
other people and then
as you say though it isn't just down to
some sort of reproductive drive it has
its imbued with meaning
and so you know you talk about the way
you can reduce complex feelings like
like love down to biology but you know
the other thing is is the values that
are woven into love so for example
somebody might feel
obsessively drawn towards someone but in
a really unhealthy or reckless way
where in the grand scheme of their life
they realize that actually you know
maybe this is an abusive relationship a
really toxic connection
but they might justify it by saying well
i'm in love with the person so that's
all the
explanation you need and then you can
start to have imagine an interlocutor
saying something like well is it really
love that you're feeling or is it more
some sort of
obsession or unhealthy desire to possess
the other person
and now you start to realize that well i
don't know if what i was feeling
subjectively was this all-consuming
thing that was almost self-justifying
and felt like a sufficient explanation
for why i was
tangled up with this person but now
somebody's giving me these value
judgments they're saying like maybe love
should only maybe we should only count
those subjective feelings as love
if they're the sorts of things that
drive us toward flourishing with other
people
and so then you start to realize that we
have some wiggle room about what kinds
of experiences we as a society want to
christen as counting as love um because
you know we might want to draw a
distinction between somebody who's
recklessly drawn towards somebody in a
totally unhealthy way and somebody who
has a sort of
long-term companion and stable
relationship with somebody that
brings out the best in both of them we
might want to distinguish between those
things conceptually maybe they don't
deserve equally the label love why do we
love the people that we do
is it a function of closeness multiplied
by time or
something like that well one of the main
main uh prerequisites is proximity i
mean there's
there's this um these cliches like
opposites attract and you know absence
makes the heart grow fonder and stuff
like that but
i remember uh when i was an
undergraduate i took this psychology
course with this
leading researcher who works on emotions
including love
named peter salloway he's now the
president of yale and um
he said basically these things just
aren't true like it's not absence that
makes the heart grow fonder if
somebody's far away it's harder to love
them i mean maybe you can make that last
for a while and some people can make a
long-distance relationship work for a
time but for the most part
that's not what stimulates the most
enduring feelings towards someone
similarly um
you know people should be pretty
compatible if you have people are
totally opposite in terms of their
values at least
it's very rare that you can get a
relationship to to work over the long
run you might have again
you know passionate attraction toward
the person or something like that but
that only will last for so long and it's
not going to be enough to sustain a
healthy relationship
so um yeah proximity is part of it but
in terms of what draws you to a
particular person nobody really knows
um there's all these theorists that say
maybe has something to do with
pheromones and it has to do with
you know some particular thing that's
like unconsciously drawing you toward
the person because of
your olfactory system recognizing
genetic compatibility
through these pheromonal cues but nobody
has a very good theory of it as
far as we know it's like we can paint in
broad brushes we can say things like if
the person has shared values as the
person is generally seen as attractive
you'll probably also see them as
attractive
but what makes a particular person seem
the most attractive to you such that you
really want to be with them
nobody has any idea what are the
necessary and sufficient conditions for
bringing that about
it's a difficult and messy world where
do drugs fit into this
well so you know before i was saying
yeah i had this idea of love as a
biopsychosocial phenomenon the bio part
of that is the part that can be
manipulated with drugs so um you know
insofar as people have begun to map
out what is going on in our brains when
we feel drawn toward people
in terms of lust so i mean testosterone
is well known to have a substantial role
in libido
and we that's a system that's been
manipulated in different ways
uh for a long time so as a kind of
unpleasant example uh people who are
um in in prison for sexual offenses
sometimes in some jurisdictions as a
condition of parole they can agree to
take androgen blocking drugs which will
radically depress their libido so you
know that you can interfere with libido
and again
testosterone is complicated it's not
just like a dial where it's like more
testosterone equals more libido and less
equals less
it acts in lots of different systems um
but roughly speaking
an increase in testosterone can can on
balance increase the sex drive
um in terms of you know uh attraction
that sort of uh you know early stage
obsessive feeling that you might have
towards someone
there's some evidence that that overlaps
a lot with the phenomenology and the
symptoms of obsessive compulsive
disorder
uh which is treated through serotonin
affecting drugs so
the most common treatment for ocd
besides cognitive behavioral therapy
is um uh selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitors which are also commonly
prescribed for depression
so there's a couple of studies out of
italy where the researchers have shown
that um
people who are in the early stages of uh
romantic
uh love where they're you know
constantly thinking about the other
person and they can't
get them out of their mind and they're
just obsessively checking their phone to
see if the other person's messaged them
they have depleted levels of the
serotonin transporter
going on and when they when they uh
kind of recover from that phase their
their serotonin levels return to normal
so they think that that's something that
could potentially be manipulated with a
common drug that we already prescribed
and then in terms of uh long-term
attachment the main
chemicals people talk about are oxytocin
uh and vasopressin
oxytocin is involved in all sorts of
processes so
what's involved in childbirth it's part
of what
causes contractions to happen it's
released through breastfeeding
so it's heavily part of the maternal
infant bond and what causes a
mother in the infant to have a very
strong connection the
uh father infant bond is similarly
mediated through oxytocin which is why
they say
they put the baby on the father's chest
so that they can start to release this
chemical together and
and have that that same sort of a bond
and oxytocin is now something that
um you can create in a laboratory and
there
are some studies that will spray this at
people's noses and directly into the
brain and see what kind of downstream
effects it has
a lot of those results don't seem very
robust it's not clear how long lasting
they are and so i'm not totally on the
oxytocin train
uh we'll see over the long run whether
those results are applicable
but the the drugs i've been focusing on
most recently sort of
sidestep a lot of this stuff and act on
the brain in a very different way
uh and those are the psychedelic drugs
and mdma which is the drug
in um ecstasy and uh
those those don't so much directly cause
a feeling of love or attraction or
attachment but they
will often put people into a state of
mind whereby they're more
open to the signals they're getting from
another person and their defenses are
depressed a little bit and so some
people are thinking about whether we
should use these drugs in the context of
couples counseling
as a way to help people who maybe have
been together for a long time
they have these grudges or these
patterns that they get into where
they're just
uh acting in a very defensive way and
the thought is that if you're in a safe
environment with a therapist and you
have a drug
like mdma which which directly
suppresses that hair triggered fear
response
over the course of the therapy session
maybe you'll be able to
you know bring up some of the things
that are hard to talk about in the
relationship and deal with them in a
more loving productive
way and then when the drug wears off you
still have your memories of what you
talked about and you can kind of
try to bring those lessons into the
relationship going forward
so that's a different kind of approach
to all this it's not about directly
intervening in these subsystems but
rather having more of a global effect
on your subconscious your subjective
experience um
that might incline you toward uh having
a more productive therapy session
but what you're doing is enhancing the
traditional effects of couples
counseling rather than trying to
allow the drug itself to just directly
somehow cause you to love your partner
more or something like that
yeah it's a the biopsychosocial
it's a biological input but it's
actually working mostly on the
psychological and on the social
area that's exactly right a colleague of
mine named david yaden just published a
paper today
called the subjective effects of
psychedelics are necessary for their
treatment effects
so what's happening is that normally
when you do a clinical trial and you're
giving people some drugs for something
you want to give them a placebo where
they don't know whether they're taking
the drug and then you measure the subtle
outcomes and whether it has some sort of
effect on their symptomology
but the problem is psychedelic drugs and
mdma don't work that way you know if
you're taking the drug
because you're having rather radically
changed subjective experience
and so you have some scientists who want
to kind of squeeze this into the old
model where they're like well we've got
to control for all that subjective
nonsense let's try to just get the
effect of the drug and you know people
have been working with these drugs for
for decades and especially those who i
guess think of it in more of a spiritual
sense or something like that they're
like you're missing the point i mean
the subjective experience is part of the
healing process it's what
you it's the meaning that you derive
from what you feel that you see
in this altered state of consciousness
um
it's the lessons that you draw out of
what it's like to feel
more vulnerable to another person that
you've known for a long time
and to try to you know recapture that
feeling and
and extend those lessons into your
normal awakened consciousness it's the
subjective experience that's part of the
healing process
and so they summon all sorts of data to
suggest that even in these clinical
trials that have been
being conducted recently at places like
johns hopkins and king's college london
you know they're doing it all in the
rigorous scientific way but those
researchers
are have a sophisticated view of these
drugs and realize it's not just like
it's it's totally different from mostly
what's used in psychiatry which is where
they try to
control for the subjective effects and
they just want to have some sort of
targeted outcome here it has a global
effect on how you're feeling
and then it's what you make of that it
is as just as as you say it's the
psychological experience and then how
you deal with that socially
that is gonna you know be most
predictive to whether it has a
a healing effect for you it doesn't
surprise me that it's causing a few
problems it seems like a big
a big paradigm shift for stuff like that
so there's two
broad sections that you give us
drugs for love and drugs for anti-love
what are some of the situations where
someone might want to use an anti-love
drug
the first case that we wrote about some
years ago was the case of somebody who's
in an objectively bad relationship and
we just wanted to
pick the worst example we could have
somebody's in an abusive relationship
with somebody
who they ought not to be with and
unfortunately what happens in many such
cases is that partly as a way of maybe
rationalizing the abuse people will
form an even stronger attachment to the
person so subjectively they might be
thinking to themselves something like
the you know the person only hits me
because they love me that kind of cliche
but then part part was going on in terms
of their attachment system is they
actually grow
ever more drawn toward the person they
can't imagine leaving the person which
just creates an even more dangerous
situation
but sometimes you have a case where
someone has the awareness
of their circumstance and knows that
they ought not to be in the relationship
but they find that they're just
their emotions are drawing them and
clutching them onto the person in a way
that they know is really dangerous for
them
and so we tried to come up with this
almost i guess a little stylized example
where we said imagine there's somebody
who knows that they need to get out of
the relationship they desire to get out
of the relationship
and they find that their first order
feelings are so powerful and so strong
that they can't motivate themselves to
do the things that they know they need
to do
to actually extricate themselves from
the relationship and so if they could
take a drug that would just
suppress those first order feelings and
allow them then to behave in a way
that's
consistent with their higher order goals
we thought that might be a
kind of a best case scenario because we
we're very reluctant to think of
anybody you know forcing these drugs on
someone wanting to be voluntary helping
people meet their higher order goals
and a sort of obvious critique is well
if somebody's in an abusive relationship
you know adding drugs to the picture
isn't what you should be doing you
should be
calling the police it's like you know if
somebody especially if somebody's
engaged in in criminal behavior
it's like the law and social support
systems or the things that should be
uh brought to bear so so i think that's
right and also you know some people
can't leave an abusive relationship not
because of their first order attachment
but because they're afraid for their
kids welfare or they're afraid that
you know um they'll be putting
themselves in danger and so again
the the really wrong way to interpret
this is as a kind of victim blaming
where it's like if you're in a bad
relationship you need to somehow take
some medication to
fix your circumstance whoever's doing
the abusing is the person who's who
needs to change
nevertheless you do find that sometimes
people are
attached to someone that they wish they
weren't attached to and it's reasonable
for them to feel that way
and so even even in this case where
you've brought in
social support services or tried all the
other methodologies you might still have
a person who says
i i just you know every night i wake up
thinking about i wishing i was back with
so-and-so even though i know that
they're really bad for me
and if that persists and persists and
persists and you've tried all the other
things we just have kind of a limit case
where we say
um you know if you could take a drug
like a selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitor which may very well suppress
some of these kind of
possessive feelings that might be a
legitimate use for such a drug in
certain circumstances when you've
exhausted all the other kind of
non-drug treatment modalities another
case that's maybe even more
straightforward is
somebody who's overwhelmingly uh and
exclusively
sexually attracted to small children so
there
is a group of people that are sometimes
called self-hating pedophiles where
basically they
are sometimes wrong to suicide because
they feel like i can't i you know they
know that they ought not to express
their sexual desire
they don't want to harm children but
they don't have any sexual desire
otherwise and they don't know what to do
themselves and they don't want to put
themselves at risk of potentially
hurting someone
and so because they're the most
stigmatized group of society or at least
one of them it's also hard for many of
these people to get treatment because
i think a lot of the popular
consciousness there's a conflation
between pedophilia which is the
name we give to the desire to have uh
sexual interactions with prepubescent
children and
sexual abuse which is the actual abusing
of children and those things don't
always go together some people who don't
have pedophilia abuse children for other
reasons
and some people who do have pedophilia
don't abuse children but are afraid to
get treatment because they know it's
going to be very stigmatized
and so uh here there are some people who
have already tried to undergo
some of these androgen blocking
treatments where they just globally try
to suppress their libido
and you know it comes with side effects
testosterone as i said before is
involved in all sorts of processes if
you have lower testosterone levels it
can um
make your bones more brittle so you're
at a higher risk of osteoporosis
it can lead to depression and so forth
so none of these interventions right now
are clean
they're all messy interventions um but
the point is that you know as we learn
more and more about what's going on
in terms of our lusts and attraction and
attachment systems and the more that we
can fine-tune these kinds of
interventions going forward
we're just going to have to face the
question of what do we want to do with
these technologies in society
if we have the power to intervene in the
neurochemical underpinnings of romantic
love and
lust and so forth we have to decide
one way or another what we want to do do
we want to ban all such technology so
that we can never intervene in our
uh neurochemical systems do we want to
try to identify some cases where we
think it might be particularly useful
and then
you know actually um lean into some of
those opportunities
and then you know the final point is
just that we're taking drugs already
that have effects on our
romantic neurochemistry we just don't
tend to think of them that way
so i once again i've mentioned selective
serotonin reuptake inhibitors
that's the most commonly prescribed drug
for depression
and you know when you run a clinical
trial on the effects of this drug you
normally are recording things like what
are your symptoms of depression or did
you experience
nausea or how's your you know maybe
you'll you'll
read about um a depression in libido
which sometimes comes along with these
drugs
but very rarely will they say and how
are your relationships going you know do
you still love your partner
um and yet these interpersonal effects
we have lots of anecdotes of people
feeling radically different toward their
partners when they take some of these
drugs but it's just not part of what we
study scientifically
and we think that's a mistake we should
study not just the personal effects of
drugs but
the interpersonal effects of drugs that
we're already using there's
women who are taking birth control
there's
married couples who've been together for
a decade or more and then they take
ssris and they fall out of love with
their partner
that we're fed
a narrative about love being able to
conquer all
because phenomenologically it's so
powerful and also the
place the ritualistic place that it's
given atop
pretty much every piece of entertainment
you know like even in the most basic
christmas film there's still a love
a love story going on and i think that
the love conquers all
narrative when it comes face to face
with stuff like this
there's a lot of difficulty
in people even me um upon reading
your book like there's a lot of
responses that i have to question myself
i notice rising like visceral
responses to things i'm very big into
personal agency and
and sovereignty and people being the
commander of their own soul and also
people learning from experiences that
are both good and bad
and trying to kind of swallow that it's
such a messy messy area
love relationships attachment lust and
uh yeah it really doesn't surprise me
that it's chaotic to try and work
through
yeah and that that brings us to that
kind of social
and even social historical dimension of
love which is that
how love is situated and celebrated or
not within a culture is something that
changes over time
so you know romantic love for long
portions of history and in many in many
social contexts was seen as a threat to
the social order precisely because it's
so powerful so romantic love
is something that might drive you to
want to form a relationship with
somebody who's not in the right
social class or somebody who's of the
wrong race let's say or the wrong sex i
mean
so when you have conservative
traditional societies that think that
marriage is primarily an economic
arrangement and it's something that
holds families together within their you
know their their proper
kind of social hierarchy love just blows
social hierarchies over the waters
at you know out of the water and so when
you have
um you know a society like ours that's
that's more about individual agency and
autonomy and celebrating people for
you know uh their own will rather than
situating them within some particular
social hierarchy
we tend to like love because love is
something that well i guess as you say
it's a bit of a tension because love can
undermine our agency in some ways and
that it makes us feel like it's driving
us to do things that we're not sure we
rationally want to do
but at the same time love kind of draws
us towards people
in such a way that uh can compel us to
cross over
traditional lines of that constrain
relationships like lines of race and
class and
social hierarchy and cast and so forth
um so we have this paradoxical
relationship with love where
on the one hand we celebrate it as this
thing that could be worth dying for
and on the other hand when we have this
very individualistic agential kind of
um ethos in the society love can
sometimes
feel like it's a power outside of
ourselves it's driving us to do things
that we're not sure we reflectively want
to do and then that way it seems to
undermine our agency so i think it's
kind of both of those things
what about pro love drugs how do they
work
yeah so one one point to say is just
that one in the same drug can be a
prolof drug or an anti-love drug
depending on
the context and which couple is using it
toward what end
so i'll stick with the example of ssris
just because
um they're so commonly used and they
have a multiplicity of effects on
different people
so just imagine that you're in that
subset of people
for whom ssris are an effective
treatment of depression and let's just
say that you
were so depressed that you couldn't get
out of bed and you certainly weren't
engaging in your relationships in any
kind of
productive healthy way so you know your
your partner's always tending to you and
starting to build resentment
because you're just not really engaging
what's going on the relationship is
heading in a bad place
and then uh you've tried all the
different treatments you know you've
done talk therapy and this and that and
the other thing and you've tried all the
things you're supposed to do and then
you say well i guess i'm gonna
as a last ditch ever try to take some
medication and see what happens now
suppose that you're one of the people
for whom that's an effective treatment
and all of a sudden you're able
to get out of bed and you know have a
conversation with your partner over
dinner and go out on a date again and so
forth so you can see how for some people
this drug depending on how it plays out
for them could be something that could
enhance a relationship
all things considered on the other hand
you mentioned the case of the long
married couple where one of them goes on
an ssri and they just don't feel
romantic love toward their partner
anymore and that's something that does
happen as well
so in addition to blocking for some
people libido
it can also have a general blunting
effect on their emotions and part of
that is if you're in such despair
that just having overall dulled emotions
is better than being massively depressed
some people would count that as a
treatment effect they'd say well that's
maybe the point of some of these ssris
but on the other hand you know some of
the phenomenology of love
requires a sense of passion a sense of
being drawn towards someone that you're
really into
and if all of your feelings are sort of
blunted and dulled and blocked then
you're going to lose some of that as
well so you do find uh some cases of
people who say
i just uh i had to stop taking the ssris
because i didn't love my partner anymore
and i've been with them for 20 years and
that wasn't acceptable to me and if i
have to deal with depression now and
then i'll deal with it
so you know the the effect is really you
know slightly orthogonal to the the
actual drug it's more like the drug
times the situation times
the couples values times what they're
dealing with and then you start to get a
map of what kind of intervention will
likely be helpful for
them rather than something that will
hinder their relationship is viagra a
love drug
yeah i mean so viagra has sort of low
level effects on the body and that it
increases blood flow
to the penis and so it can help people
with penises have erections and so
insofar as that's an important component
of the sexual repertoire of a given
couple then you can see how it can have
knock-on effects that would be
advantageous in a kind of higher level
love sense so you know
uh sex and orgasm uh are release
oxytocin which we've been talking about
and oxytocin is something that um
you know undergirds the attachment bond
so
you know there's lots of ways to to be
close to a person that doesn't involve
penetrative sex but nevertheless if
that's something that you value if
that's something that you and your
partner um
you know take some particular joy in
than if you have a drug that enables you
to
to to facilitate that kind of activity
and that brings you closer together and
that causes you to be releasing oxytocin
together in a particularly potent
circumstance then you can see how that
would have ramifications for the
relationship
yeah yeah can drugs make straight people
turn gay
are we going to have straight conversion
therapy happening soon
yeah that's that's very interesting so
you know people have been trying to use
drugs for a long time to convert gay
people into straight people and largely
in uh ineffectively and you know there's
a whole
social campaign and government programs
and laws that are being passed to try to
discourage this because it's seen
rightly i think as
an unjust pressure that's placed on
sexual orientation minorities to try to
squeeze them into the majority mold
rather than just saying listen let's
just
let people have the sexual orientations
that they want to have um
there are some cases that we talk about
in the book of super religious
communities like
cultural orthodox jewish communities
where same-sex
activity and attraction is totally
forbidden masturbation is forbidden
anything that's not procreative sex
within the context of marriage is
looked down upon and highly stigmatized
and what will happen is that some of
these young
yeshiva students will go to their
counselors or the rabbis and they'll say
you know i i have these same-sex desires
and i know i can't act on them
because of the values of the community
and perhaps their own reflective values
and and they say that makes me really
depressed and
as a consequence of this the rabbis and
the psychiatrists will get together and
say well if you prescribe a high dose of
a selective serotonin reuptake inhibitor
there's a there's a sort of on label
purpose for doing that which is it
should treat the depression but
the idea is that it will also hopefully
have the side effect of
depressing the libido and so it's not a
conversion drug and that it doesn't
cause the person to suddenly have
opposite sex sexual desire but it does
just kind of kill their sexual desire
altogether so it's a sort of
quasi-conversion drug and that it's it's
at least meant to dampen or interfere
with the naturally occurring same-sex
attractions that this person has
um and you know that raises all sorts of
problems i mean
in the book we suggest that certainly
anybody who's you know any
minor shouldn't have any such drug
thrust upon them as a way of converting
their sexuality
but this is something where kind of
progressive politics
comes into conflict with itself because
we tend to think that there should be
freedom of choice you know just let
people make decisions
in line with their own values but
there's some corners of progressive
politics that only like people to have
progressive values so you can imagine
you know let's say you're a 30
30 year old uh you know conservative
jewish person or christian or a muslim
and you say you know my relationship
with god which i take to require that i
ought not to be
involved in same-sex relationships will
be improved if i
didn't have these desires now i as a
secular progressive person be like oh we
need to have a conversation like you
shouldn't be
thinking that and maybe there's some
better way of reading the torah than the
one that you're reading
but on the other hand you know the
liberal progressive value says that you
can try to persuade people but you
shouldn't coerce them and so if the
person says i don't want to be gay
what we say we say is wow you have
internalized homophobia and we need to
treat you and take care of you but now
we're starting to kind of trip over
ourselves because it sounds like we're
telling the person that they can't think
what they think
and so this is a very touchy area yeah
it's hard to know what to say about this
and then you raise the point of what if
some straight people wanted to be
gay i mean maybe that's better you know
these opposite sex relationships are so
complicated
and have all these issues people dress
better they've got cooler hair
yeah better skin exactly men and women
don't really understand each other and
you know
so um we talked about that in the book
we say
just to raise a real life example of
this back i think in the 1980s there was
this um
group of these radical feminists out of
leeds who
called themselves the revolutionary
feminists and their argument was that
um you know the main political goal is
to fight the patriarchy
and according to to their vision of this
uh
men are sort of the enemy in the
patriarchy and women have to band
together and you shouldn't have to rely
on them to have romantic relationships
and so they
saw lesbianism as a political virtue now
so they characterize themselves as
political lesbians and the issue is
it's not that they were viscerally
attracted to other women they didn't
necessarily feel that way so either they
could
go through the motions or consign
themselves to a life of celibacy or you
could imagine if they had some ability
to actually intervene and tinker with
their neurochemistry and
uh cost stuff to feel
attractive they could help them support
our goals and then you think well that's
a sort of thing maybe we should support
um you know so some colleagues of mine
have
you know we raised this example and we
knew it was gonna be controversial and i
still don't know exactly what to think
about it but i am
a little bit persuaded by the arguments
of uh some critics of ours
who said you know in an ideal world if
there wasn't homophobia
sure people should be able to tinker
around with their sexual orientation
and you know all in the project of
self-creation and
people should be attracted to whoever
they want to be that should be the sort
of thing that you could exercise some
agency over
but we don't live in an ideal world we
live in a non-ideal world where we have
a lot of people who are
asymmetrically pressured to change their
sexual orientation
and so it would be better all things
considered if we just didn't have this
technology we just shouldn't even
develop it
um and so i you know i i'm persuaded uh
to some extent by their views that maybe
it's better for us to just you know
learn how to you know once we can all
get to a place in society where we're
not
uh you know being bigoted and prejudiced
toward people because of their sexual
orientations maybe we shouldn't be
tinkering with our sexual orientation so
much as fixing the wider political
problem
but if we get to some utopia where
people aren't uh you know hating on each
other because of who they want to have
sex with
and people want to engage in a process
of self-creation that involves
experimenting with their own sexual
orientation i think there's some trends
in society that are actually
supportive of that i mean i think in the
really the youngest generation now i
think there's
an emerging view about sexuality that
why why shouldn't it be something that's
a little bit more
fluid you know a lot of people are
thinking of gender and gender identity
is the sort of thing that you should be
able to play with rather than something
that's this inherent essentialist thing
within you
and i think there's that's that's
starting to affect some people's views
about sexuality too they're like well
why should i think of sexuality as this
you know inborn
immovable thing that isn't uh subject to
any kind of modification by my own
desires or values and so you know this
this conversation's never going to go
away but it's certainly a messy
conversation and that's
that's about the state of it right now
is there a limit to
how much we should step into the
programming of the human body how far
can we alter our desires and motivations
before we're no longer ourselves
one general risk in intervening in
biological systems is that
biological systems came about through a
tinkering process of natural
selection not through well i guess it
depends on your views if you're a
creationist you might think god just sat
there with
his blueprint and created humans
according to some particular plan but
you'd probably be opposed to tinkering
with god's plan for theological reasons
but if you're a secular science-minded
person you you think that our bodies and
brains came about
through the you know millions of years
of tinkering through evolution that
means that it's not easy to reverse
engineer
the blueprint we don't know exactly how
all this stuff works in there and so
it's easy to
mess up a complex system and it's often
much easier to mess it up than it is to
improve it
and so the general risk when you're
putting drugs and technologies in to try
to re-engineer
uh you know something about human nature
is that you may think that you're
improving the system along one dimension
but you don't understand the system
enough to realize all the off target
effects that you're having
and so that's always a risk now somebody
who wanted to disagree with what i just
said would say
of course that's true but you know
nevertheless in psychiatry we try to do
our best
we we have some drugs that we uh
prescribe for certain purposes we don't
always know exactly how they're gonna
work at which dose but
some people are in a bad enough
situation that
having access to drugs even if they not
might not have a perfect tailored effect
will all things considered improve their
situation
even if there's also some side effects
that they don't want and we should
continue to try
unless we think that what we have now is
ideal
we have some reason to try to at least
keep looking into the question of
whether we can improve ourselves
whether we can improve i mean just take
an example of uh human beings
as political creatures you know it we
have
political turmoil all over the world we
have genocides we
have polarization we have people
electing authoritarian leaders and so
forth
it seems like something about us humans
is not ideal we could do better than
this
and if something about our tribal
psychology that we've inherited from you
know the ancient plains of africa
is something that we could improve if we
could through some means or another
whether it's biologically or otherwise
you know uh change our tribalistic
tendencies
some people would say that's we live in
a world where tribalism isn't good for
us anymore
maybe it was ten thousand years ago but
it's not good for us anymore
we've constructed a world for ourselves
that's in some ways
out of tune with the psychological
disposition that we've inherited from
our ancestors and so if we want to make
the most of our lives together in this
complicated uh multicultural globally
connected world
we may actually need to intervene at the
level of our own psychology and biology
to try to enhance ourselves to meet
the the challenges of the time so people
who have kind of more of a transhumanist
bent tend to be
more open to these kinds of strategies
and other people who are more concerned
about messing up a complex biological
system will be more reluctant
but somewhere between those two extremes
is probably you know a path forward
is there not something as well that
probably is a hangover from our time in
a religious society
where people feel there is this essence
within us this sort of soul
something ethereal that shouldn't be
tampered with
to do with our form and that i think is
clashing up against
a world in which we have vaccinations
like the the advantage and the reason
that most people most sane people
don't disagree with vaccines is because
the
binary is this better is a world better
with vaccines than without
is fairly obvious but then if you roll
that clock forward
and you just decide to pick this
particular drug which has this effect
but the price is
that you need to pay this particular
side effect with it as well and
it becomes a value judgment the
suffering of somebody who decides
to um go to germany or switzerland or
wherever it is to go and be euthanized
like what's that you know we've got a
world where you can elect it's a very
difficult process and in some places
illegal
but where you can elect to be killed
because the suffering of your life is
not worth continuing it and it would
literally be better to be dead
in a world where you've got that it
opens the door for an awful lot of other
uh people to put their hand in the air
and say actually i i i've got this pain
in my leg and i'd really quite like that
fixing and
actually my sexual orientation is
against my religious belief or
actually like girls are totally like
awful and i just can't i don't really
understand them so i just want to like
have sex with my mates and play xbox or
whatever it might be you know we have
this
kind of full gamut now yeah um
and i think that we're seeing
the paradox of choice play out a little
bit here
and the bizarreness of a
conservative religiously based society
constrained choice in a way that
actually made life a lot simpler and a
lot easier and we're now having to ask
much harder questions
because we're in a meritocracy where you
can do whatever you want
there's so many interesting points that
are raised by what you said so
thank you thank you brian that's a
that's a wonderful compliment from an
esteemed philosopher like yourself
well so so one thing i'm thinking about
is people have a concern that technology
will be used to override or interfere
with
human nature conceived of some way and
the way that debate often plays out is
you have the bioconservatives who say we
just should be tampering with what we've
got
it would be much better for us to try to
create a better environment for
ourselves to live in to you know work on
our values but we shouldn't keep trying
to
interfere with our biological essence in
some kind of a way
and then you have the bio liberals who
say you know unless you're
bio-liberals
yeah you know this you know the these
political disputes play out in so many
different areas and and
in debates about human enhancement is
certainly one of them you know the
bio-liberals would say
um kind of what i was saying before
there's no reason to think that our
current
uh blueprint is ideal and certainly it's
not ideal given our environment and
there's only so much changing of our
environment we could do so at least one
of the options that should be on the
table is
tinkering with our own brains in biology
and then another point that they'll make
a sort of a level two move in the debate
is to say well let's think about human
nature for a second what is it that
makes us different from all the other
animals well one thing is that we're
inventors uh we
we do change our environment we don't
just live in harmony with the trees in
some idyllic
place that we imagine from the distant
past but we transform our environment we
create technology we change ourselves
part of human nature is to be
self-intervening in certain kinds of
ways
now you still have some people who have
this view that that's all misguided we
should go back to living in harmony with
the trees what are we doing and you i
think you start to see now people
who are really concerned about the pace
of technological change we're concerned
about the fact that we're on our
computers all the time who are concerned
about the fact we're addicted to our
devices and so forth
and i think they have a fair point when
they say maybe that idea of actually
simplifying life and living on a farm
and living in harmony with nature
is not so bad i mean why do we think
we're going to technologically solve our
way out of our own problems you know the
planets dying and uh we're devastating
whole ecologies and so forth maybe we
should maybe this idea that we can just
if we're smart enough
we can with a technical fix you know
solve the problems that we've created
for ourselves maybe that's just
a doomed general approach and we should
get off the technology and stop taking
drugs for every different thing and just
eat healthier and exercise more and
stuff like that so
i mean with all these things i feel like
there's usually a good insight in
anybody's view i think it's right that
there's probably a lot we could do
that doesn't involve high-tech
interventions into our bodies but rather
just
living better and you know paying
attention to what we eat and
getting good exercise and not being on
the internet all the time those are
things that we should do
on the other hand i think there are
people who go too far in that direction
so when you know anesthesia for pain
control was first
discovered you know first laughing gas
was being uh
tested the humphrey davies i think and
then eventually that got used
with um ether that they were using for
pain control a lot of people said
well this is really unnatural you know
if you're giving birth for example
should be painful that's
that's just part of what it is to be
human it's been that way for millions of
years what all of a sudden we're just
going to take out the pain out of giving
birth or the pain of surgery
i mean surgeries too uh there's some
descriptions of this time where
you know if you had say a breast cancer
and you had to have a surgery to have
that removed then there was no
pain control maybe you'd have some bite
down on this bit of wood yeah
yeah and it's just excruciating so
there's this one account that i was
reading in a book recently of this woman
who recorded her story in great detail
about what it was like to be conscious
and have her breast removed because of
the surgery before pain control is
available
and you know some people sort of gave a
sense a sense of
meaning to this where they said well
this is just part of what it is to be us
flawed and and fragile humans is that
we're supposed to have certain kinds of
suffering
now other people look at this case and
say the thought of undergoing a surgery
without anesthesia
is that's the height of cruelty and you
have all sorts of like human rights
declarations that say people have a
right to pain control
so you know again we have all sorts of
conflicted values about what we think we
should
be doing here and i don't think there's
any one-size-fits-all answer i think you
can be ideological and dogmatic in any
direction
you can be the person who says i won't
even use vaccines because they're
unnatural and it's like
okay but all things considered it's
probably worth taking
and then you can have the people who say
you know we shouldn't even listen to
what's natural because you know that's
just a fallacy
but it's like yeah that's true it's true
that what's natural isn't necessarily
what's good you know pestilence is
natural and it's not good cancer is
natural and it's not good
but it's also true that natural systems
you know evolve to solve certain kinds
of problems over millennia
and so when we come along with our
high-tech
uh mindset on we may think that we've
solved that problem or we can outsmart
nature and sometimes we can
but other times what happens is we
locally solve a problem and we create
much worse problems
you know in terms of the side effects
and then we're constantly trying to
catch up with our own interventions so
you know i guess it's good that there
are bio liberals and bio conservatives
duking out with each other in the
literature
because i think that somewhere between
that dialectic is going to be
uh where the answer lies is we're going
to keep doing science and technology and
and learning about how the natural world
works and sometimes we're going to find
that it's all things considered
best to try to intervene in it as far as
we can predict what we think the
downstream consequences are going to be
and i think it's right that we need to
be much better about learning how to
you know develop social systems that
allow us to
make peace with each other and live in
harmony with the world without always
uh you know looking for a technological
quick fix and so
you know both of these both of these
views have some wisdom in them i think
the problem that i see with regards to
implementing
the more progressive biological
enhancements
approach for relationships is the order
of magnitude complexity that you come up
against you've not just got the first
second third order effects for yourself
and it's a multiplicative relationship
between you and the other person
and then it will become self referential
too
so you will do a thing it will affect
you in one two three four ways down the
line
that person will be affected one two
three four and then those
effects will begin to interact with each
other also
um i think yeah but of course that's
true
even setting aside biotechnology so just
take
let's say that i go on a meditation
retreat for a month and i feel that i've
discovered some deep insights into
the nature of consciousness or something
and then i come back to my partner who's
you know really anxious
and going to work and has all these
different values we we might have
something going on between us that we
have to deal with just because of a
change that i underwent through
non-biotechnologically mediated means so
there's a risk i think
there's there's ways that we can have
changes to ourselves
self-discovery and um you know just
changes in our values watching the wrong
youtube video
yeah and then going down you know some
some uh rabbit hole or
having a religious conversion some
people may have so i mean also giving
birth to a child is a transformative
experience it totally restructures your
value
system and what your priorities are and
so forth and so a lot of couples
when the child comes along find that
whoa our relationship to each other is
very different now
and so we have to just remember that
like something being
biologically based doesn't necessarily
mean that it's more radical
in the effects that it brings about than
things that are non-biologically based
you know you you can
you can have lots of big changes and
relationships have to learn how to adapt
and adjust and be elastic
if if a couple wants to stay together
through the sorts of changes that life
throws at us anyway
and so what you want to do when you're
thinking about adding biotechnology to
the mix is
can you identify that subset of cases
where you'll be able to bring about a
change that you have
reasonably good reason to predict will
help the relationship improve rather
than deteriorate and so
you take the example of if i have ptsd
and i see there's this trial for mdma
assisted psychotherapy
and i see that 70 of the people in the
trials previous to me
have shown radical treatment effects
where they no longer have nightmares at
night and they're not
on 49 different pills to treat symptoms
you have pretty good reason to think
that
it's rational for you to undertake this
drug mediated experience if you have if
you think it's going to improve your
ptsd situation
then you have a pretty good reason to
think that not having ptsd is going to
be good for your relationship
so you know you're never going to be
perfect in your predictions but
biotechnology and non-biotechnology can
both have radical effects
on our lives and it's really just how we
integrate those effects into our ongoing
narrative with the other person and our
ongoing
sense of ourselves i don't know what it
is it might be something to do with this
sacred inner ethereal being
feeling feelings is hard right like i
get i get that you know going through a
breakup
is painful but nerfing that
cutting off all of the sharp edges of
life by deciding to tranquilize yourself
away from bad feelings
to me seems first like a cop-out
secondly it's massively against the
the um philosophy of a meritocracy which
i'm massively
in favor for uh and thirdly there's
learnings to be
made there's lessons to learn from
falling in and out of love are we
risking
losing them um i'll go back to our
familiar example of ssris just because
it's a familiar example and then i'll
try to talk about psychedelic drugs
which tend to work differently
um you have two general types of
experiences that people will
tell you about when they take an ssri
for depression
one type that they'll say is you know
i was depressed because i was in a bad
situation my emotions were telling me
something real about the world like my
job sucks and i'm in a bad relationship
and i need to get out of the
relationship
and once i took this drug it just kind
of papered over all that
all that emotion which is not actually
helpful because although it allows me to
sort of function in my current situation
it disincentivizes me from changing my
situation which is the thing i really
ought to do because those initial
emotions of despair and sadness and
distress were
giving me some real signal amidst all
the noise that was some really important
information i should have paid attention
to
so those kinds of situations you know it
it depends sometimes just functioning
is the best a person can hope for but
other times you'd say you shouldn't
really be on that drug man you should
pay attention to the depression get out
of the relationship and change your
circumstance that's what you need
other people will say you know i was
going through my life and maybe
certain things were good and certain
things were bad but this feeling of
depression
was so out of proportion to what was
actually happening that it was
disabling me from being able to
participate in life and when i took this
ssri what it did was it felt like it
lifted
the blanket of depression off of me and
allowed my true self or whatever to
to actually begin to engage with the
world i can remember being a joyful
person when i was a kid
and and from whatever happened where
whatever's going on with me i was
feeling depressed all the time
this drug allowed me to remove that
barrier to flourishing
and then kind of have my true self come
out so
i think you're right that if the effect
of a drug was just uniformly to block
people's ability to
access genuine information from their
emotional and intuitive lives
that would be bad but some drugs seem to
be able to
uh depending on how they're used in the
person who's using them remove barriers
between
people and their emotional lives so just
to take the ptsd
mdma example when people come back from
the war and they've just seen bloodshed
and slaughter and horror
and they have just nightmares and deep
traumas that they've just had to
cover over so they can keep on fighting
and then they come home and now you know
the slightest sound outside makes them
freak out and they're having aggression
toward their partner and all this kind
of crazy stuff
they go to talk therapy and they say
listen i've got all these
symptoms of ptsd what can i do and the
therapist says well we're gonna have to
talk about your time in the war
and the person just shuts down they're
like i want to talk about that stuff
so in this case what happens under these
mdma assisted psychotherapy sessions for
at least the people who so far have gone
through these trials
is that when the person says tell me
about you know
the last time you were in baghdad
instead of flipping out the person
feels warm and soft and safe
enough to just kind of go there and they
can bring up that memory
without having a freak out and then they
can talk about it with a therapist and
then they can actually work through some
of these underlying issues
and then what's what seems to be
happening is that after two or three
such sessions
again about 70 of the people in these
early trials just don't have ptsd
anymore they don't meet the diagnostic
criteria and they aren't taking all
these other pills that they've been
taking before
so sorry you found some guy that went
from an 80
out of 100 down to an eight or something
yeah yeah exactly so one of the people
that we talked about in the book uh
was an early enrollee in one of these
trials
who was you know maxing out the scale
and had tried everything he was suicidal
he'd been on every kind of drug he was
living out in the back woods in north
carolina as i recall
uh just drinking himself to death
basically and then he heard from a
friend about this
uh study that was going on with mdma
assisted psychotherapy and he figured he
had nothing else to lose
so he went into the trial and again
because he wasn't just trying to
you know alcohol is another drug that
many people use to avoid dealing with
their feelings
i mean let's just use alcohol for
example alcohol can have both of these
effects too right in some cases
you feel like [ __ ] and then you just
drink yourself uh into a stupor so that
you don't have to deal with
it but of course many people have also
had the situation being there with your
close friend and it's probably because
you're a little bit tipsy that you're
willing to kind of bring up some stuff
that maybe you otherwise wouldn't have
uh wanted to bring up because your
inhibition has been lowered and so
yeah it's just you know any of these
different drugs can have a multiplicity
of effects
including alcohol including ssris but
certainly in the case of the psychedelic
drugs when they're used in a therapeutic
context and mdma it seems to have
an effect for many people that they
describe as as greater authenticity
they feel that all of a sudden they're
in touch with their emotions in a way
that they haven't been for many years
they feel like
all the defense mechanisms they've built
up to just
get through the social world and to deal
with their demons
those those start to break down and they
actually have to confront you know
really in a frank way some of the basic
facts of their inner life
and if they're in a safe environment
they can work through that stuff for
many of them it can be very positive
experience some people have bad trips
some people face the demons and it's not
good
um and so that's why it's so important
to you know really be careful about the
circumstances under which these kinds of
drug-assisted experiences are are had
but um
yeah i think that kind of gets at the
heart of your question yeah
there's something about it that makes me
feel uncomfortable and
i think part of it comes from
a fear and an understanding that most
people
don't like facing their feelings that
there is a opiate crisis in america
ridiculous the only place in the world
where you can essentially recreationally
get your hands on
things that stop you from feeling
feelings and given that choice i don't
think that most people's willpowers are
the average general public willpower is
sufficiently strong to not just take
an increasingly complex series of
cocktails in order to
well i want to find a partner but
actually i'm a little bit obsessive so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take a drug that's going to dampen down
my excessiveness
like if i fall in love with a girl
who is augmenting her biology with drugs
have has she conned me like who might
who am i in love with
like and if she continues taking that
for the rest of time
and i don't know does it matter you know
i know that we're getting into some
tighter and tighter circles here
ethically and morally
but this is the interesting [ __ ] so this
is this is where i want to go
yeah so there's questions of like who is
your authentic self and there's
different theories about that
um one sort of general type of theory is
that
when you're having an emotional response
to something and and you
upon reflection would sort of endorse
that way that you're behaving then
people think well that's an authentic
response
the classic example in philosophy is the
willing or the unwilling addict
so if you have somebody who's deeply
addicted to something but then when they
stand outside of their behavior and they
look at it they're just judging
themselves they're like this is not what
i want to do you know i don't want to
keep going back to the heroin or
whatever it is
then some people say that addiction is
not an authentic expression of the
person's self because it's something
that their intention with and they want
to get rid of
um whereas if if you have somebody who
has integrated their drug use into their
very sense of self and it's you know
their whole way of understanding
themselves in the world is based around
the fact that their friends do drugs
with them and they do it in a certain
way and they love that way that it feels
there's some views that you know drug
use could be part of a person's
authentic self at least
as far as they understand it um another
way of thinking about it is sort of
we have you know we have memories we
have our dispositions we have our
emotions
we have all sorts of stuff going on in
our mental life and some of those things
are easier to dislodge than others
so take the example of the religious
person who has same sex attraction
um uh josh noah experimental philosopher
and
and his colleagues did some really
interesting work on this where this
person
um you know has two kinds of commitments
here one is their relationship to god as
they see it and the other is their
same-sex attraction and if you ask
liberals and conservatives what is their
true self
you find that the conservatives are like
obviously the christianity is the true
self and the same-sex attraction is just
this annoying like biological thing
that's getting in the way of the
person's ability to live according to
their true values
and then the progressives are all like
obviously that christianity nonsense
needs to just
get out of the way and obviously the
same sex attraction you know it's this
is a gay person who just needs to accept
the fact that they're gay
and so you start to see that we have we
have value judgments that
that affect what bits of our inner life
do we want to kind of stake a flag in
and then build the rest of it around and
some of that can be down to ideological
commitment sometimes it can be down to
just what we find we can't change about
ourselves
so that's that's a good example if you
have a you know a gay person in a small
town
where everybody's super religious and
there's a lot of anti-gay sentiment
and they find that nevertheless you know
they can't help these kinds of feelings
and that they feel
the most safe and truly themselves and
in touch with their inner life when they
um allow themselves to act on their
feelings
then you you find many of them taking
the very difficult decision to leave
their communities
and and they but it's not a clean break
you know it's like imagine you're
somebody who really all your friends and
your family and you know
every sunday you go to the church and
that's where you're used to you know
experiencing
really deep emotions it's not an easy
thing to leave all that behind
but for some people their feeling of
same sex attraction is so central to
their sense of self and it's so
immovable
and it's so tied up with the rest of the
way that they view themselves in the
world
that that's the trade-off that they have
to make and it's conceivable you can
imagine somebody making a different
trade-off that's their feeling their
relationship to god was precisely yeah
that's that's what i was thinking that
because we get back to what we
brought up at the very beginning about
the phenomenological complexities that
we're coming up against here
there is no if this then that objective
metric
that we can look at to say well actually
you're you're
seven gay but you're only six and a half
jewish
therefore like yeah gay wins like go
team gay
sort of see you at pride like we don't
have
a way to gauge that and
increasingly this year upon reading and
learning about self-deception and
just how tiny the sliver of our own
motivations that we're
privy to we get we get to know
absolutely nothing
we're like a rider on the back of an
elephant who's also got blinkers on
going through some of those kanye west
glasses that kind of block out almost
half of your vision
you get to see nothing you don't know
why your motivations are the way that
they are
so then presuming that you know what's
best for you or that anybody else does
is almost impossible well i mean
so i'm thinking of john stuart mill's
concept of experiments in living i mean
that's not his concept maybe other
people have
said that too but um you kind of just
have to try you just have to go out
there and live your life
like you know suppose you're living in a
small town and all you know is
jesus loves you and god doesn't want you
to be gay or that's what you think you
know
but then you get on the internet you
find out that there's some christian
communities that are accepting of gay
people
and also you're like oh i don't know
maybe there is a world for me where i
could both have my
relationship to god and you know live
out my my sexual attractions in the way
they're important to me
and so maybe you you know chat with
those people online and then you you
feel
loved by them and you feel like actually
this feels like a community i feel
understood i feel like the whole me
gets to exist with these people and you
know if you didn't have the internet and
you didn't have that experience you
might not have known phenomenologically
what it was like to feel fully embraced
by a group of people who both accept you
as a religious person and as a gay
person let's say um
so you know or or if you've just never
had an experience with somebody the same
sex and then you do and you find that
you finally feel complete for the first
time in your life or something like that
that's information
and you know it's true that we might
really think we're on to something and
we think we've harmonized all the
different aspects of ourself and then
some little stimulus comes in and all of
a sudden we're confused again and we're
like oh maybe i don't
actually care about that but man that's
just living like you know sometimes
we're gonna find a pretty stable
arrangement for ourselves where our
inner life our set of values our
community
our beliefs all kind of hang together in
a way that feels like it's got some
stability to it
and that's that's kind of the goal i
think and you know
one way you can find out what that
stable arrangement is for your
dispositions your drives your beliefs
your
values and your community is is by
living in the world
and by trying out different kinds of
things and going with your hunch and
seeing what happens and
trying a change um and but that just is
the process of being a person
is trying these things out and seeing
where do i find that i'm the most
uh you know at peace with myself where
do i find that
i'm able to engage with others in a way
that feels healthy and not toxic
when do i feel like i'm getting lots of
good sleep at night uh
when when is my health good when you
know and and when you find that
arrangement of things and you know
different cultures have different wisdom
traditions that are going to try to
nudge you in certain
directions it's not like it's totally
random some things for most people are
not good things to do
uh some things for most people are good
things to do you know how you know
approaching relationships in a way
that's not built around
anxiety and mistrust but around you know
honesty and
trust those generally speaking that's
going to be good for most people um
with maybe some exceptions so that's
yeah i think the experiments in living
is the only way to approach that there
is you're right there isn't one obvious
answer we just
sign your name on to some life plan and
go with that and and
you you only know by bumping into stuff
and seeing how it feels
what are the other common criticisms
that you're coming up against or the
people coming up against
when they propose augmenting
relationships with drugs
i think the main thing that people are
worried about is
that the feelings will be inauthentic i
think this very thing that we're talking
about they think well isn't
isn't whatever i'm feeling without the
intervention of a drug my true feelings
and then whatever i have when i have a
drug is some sort of
drug-induced sensation and i really
think that this has to do with
a misunderstanding about what is going
on with
some of these drugs so let's take the
case of cyloside from magic mushrooms
um there's different theories now about
what exactly is going on when you take
this drug but
but uh one thing that it does is it
binds to the serotonin receptors
in uh in the place of serotonin and
uh it causes what it seems like is a
is a dampening down of the kind of
global network of neurochemical
processes and
and and uh uh brain areas that uphold
kind of the ego it's sometimes called
the default mode network but it's
basically your sense of self
that that's just hanging out with you
all the time that kind of quiets down
and so this is why some people are
thinking of
um or will share that they feel at one
with the universe or they feel like the
boundaries between themselves and others
are breaking down it's because
you know the model of yourself that you
have is just a fiction that your brain
is
running most of the time to kind of make
sense of the world you have to have kind
of an inner
self that maps onto things and is is the
subject of the experiences that you're
having
and you know when people have psychotic
experiences or schizophrenia or so forth
those are other ways in which the self
can
break down and that's not a very safe
experience to have but um
if it's under a controlled kind of uh
circumstances
suddenly feeling like wow it's not all
about me and i see that other people are
also here and their
experiences are meaningful to them um
you know that's at the heart of many
kinds of
wisdom traditions and religions and so
forth is this idea of getting out of
your own ego
and you know giving proper weight to the
other conscious beings around you
another thing it seems to do is to kind
of flush out
some of your uh your kind of
belief structures that have become rigid
so
i'll just illustrate this with an
example let's say that you're
a little kid and you're walking down the
street and you see a leaf
on the sidewalk and you just are
fascinated by it you're like this is so
amazing you're just really in tune with
your environment because it's new
information and you don't yet know
what's important and what's not
important
and then as we grow up and we get
socialized and our parents says you know
come along we need to get to school we
learn what's important and what's not
important according to
the dicta of society so now believes
aren't important and getting to school
is important
but of course it's not wrong that leaves
are amazing these are amazing it's just
that we've learned to stop paying
attention to them
and similarly you know when we get into
our relationships we can often get into
a rut with people
where we stop seeing our partner with
fresh eyes and we just get into these
stupid habits where they say something
we get irritated we act defensively and
then they respond defensively and then
we have an argument
and it's the thousandth time that this
happened in the last 10 years
well what by by just temporarily washing
out
that kind of uh stimulus response loop
that we can get into it allows us to see
the world with fresh eyes and so again
the kind of when you when people see
somebody who's having a drug experience
and they make fun of them because
they're looking at the wall and they
seem to think the wall is so fascinating
i think there's a sense in which that
person is not wrong why isn't the wall
fascinating
why isn't this flower next to me
fascinating why isn't the partner that
i've been
living with for 10 years not miraculous
to perceive
they are it's just that we've stopped
seeing them that way because we've got
into a pattern
and so some some of what this drug does
is it just kind of wipes out some of
those patterns for a little bit so we
can see things with fresh eyes and then
we decide what we want to do with that
the effect of the drug wears off and
there are some long-lasting kind of
heightened sense of resilience for many
people where they feel for some months
they feel a little bit changed by the
experience
um but you know they have their memories
they have their values you don't
completely become a new person and then
you decide what you want to learn from
that experience
and again there are lots of ways that we
can do this to ourselves we can go climb
a mountain
and behold the beauty of nature we can
meditate we can um
see a really good film that just totally
challenges our
our preconceptions about you know what
people are like
and so you know some of these drug
mediated experiences are
are just other ways of putting ourselves
into an altered state of consciousness
whereby we don't lose
everything that was ever authentic to us
but we certainly have an experience
which throws up new information
and puts us into an altered state of
mind whereby we're able to engage with
that information
with a kind of new perspective and you
know there's lots of ways we can do that
the potent way to do it that's more
reliable than some of those other ways
yeah i i don't know i the naturalistic
fallacy in trying to avoid it
is something that i found myself coming
up against constantly
whilst reading your book i'm like yeah
okay like just because it's what's
always happened like it doesn't
necessarily need to be that way
then there's another level to it that
the listeners may be feeling which is
some sort of sacredness to do with a
relationship
that it's something that perhaps
shouldn't be beholden
to this new world you know there's this
few
islands of um
purity that are left that haven't been
kind of molested and i suppose you could
argue
well we're living in a world with tinder
and only fans and booty pictures like
how has relationships not be molested by
the modern world
but at least perhaps not by
performance-enhancing drugs uh outside
of viagra
um and i'm aware that it's it's just
gradations all the way down
right it's just what is your particular
tolerance level for
manipulation or for new stuff new [ __ ]
um
and i still i still remain sort of
unconvinced on what my own position is
here i don't know
and i'd be fascinated to know what the
listeners think as well just leave it as
a comment or
like let me know but um i'm
i'm unsure what's your what's your sort
of personal stance on this would you
take
drugs to enhance your relationship
so for most of my life i've been just
because of my upbringing i was raised in
a very conservative religious household
so when i'm
talking about all these religious
examples i'm drawing from my own
experience where you know
that that was my sense of the world was
you know there's right and wrong and
drugs are bad and
god is good and and that was kind of my
my simplistic worldview for a long time
since i spent all these years
researching these drugs i've had to
change my view a little bit because i've
seen
so many accounts of people who seem to
have had transformatively good
experiences
um on account of them and so my my
mind's been opened a little bit but i
think i still retain a sense of caution
or skepticism or concern so i share your
view i'm not kind of an enthusiast for
biotechnological enhancement i'm really
not um i think that
you know i like reading history i like
reading philosophy i think the stoic
philosophers from
you know thousands of years ago had a
lot of good ideas about how we can live
a good life and they weren't talking
about doing a whole bunch of drugs
they were talking about doing meditation
um
and you know so they were interested in
altering your consciousness and they
thought you know the judgments that you
had about the world and the sort of
responses you had to the impressions
that came in
was what being a virtuous person was all
about it was it was about how to respond
to the world in
a responsible way um and so they were
big into something like meditation um
so yeah i'm not uh i'm not thinking that
everybody should rush out and try these
drugs and for for myself i think of it
as something that i would want to try
having having deeply invested in laying
the right groundwork for making changes
that are within my
non-drug mediated control so a
conservative way to approach these
things would be to say if you're in a
relationship with someone that you you
value the relationship let's say you
have shared values
you have um goals together you have a
good reason
all things considered to try to maintain
your relationship and let's just say
you've tried all the other things
you've gone on romantic vacations you've
i don't know
got sexy underwear or whatever it is
that they say in the magazines you know
you've gone to couples counseling you've
done all the different things to try to
bring a feeling of
uh excitement back into the relationship
um
and and it just it doesn't seem to be
working now one thing you might say is
well i guess the relationship's over i
don't know we tried all the stuff
and it didn't work and so you know
that's the signal that we need to break
up
um and that's one thing you could do
sure no hard feelings to anybody who
does that
but you can imagine somebody who says
you know um
what if we you know supposing that these
clinics arise in the next 10 years or so
which looks pretty likely where people
will be able to have
psychedelic enhanced couples therapy
um let's give it a try let's see what
happens if we can just
go into this place together put our
shared values on the table talk to the
therapist about what we want to
accomplish learn about the effects of
this drug recognize that it will put us
into a different state of mind for a
while
the effects of the drug won't be
permanent they'll wear off
but but while we're in that altered
state of mind maybe we'll be able to
kind of
recapture rekindle or um explore some
things together that
just because of the pattern that we're
in we aren't able to really do by our
own volition
and and see what happens and then if it
turns out that as some of the people who
have been in these trials recently say
you know i i look at my partner
like when we first met again you know
all of a sudden i can see it's not that
they
aren't there it's that i stopped seeing
them and for some people
having the the direct influence of a
drug to kind of wipe out some of their
patterned ways of thinking and allow
them to see what's right in front of
them with new eyes
does allow them to kind of um remember
and re-experience why it is that they
value the relationship in the first
place and to me that doesn't seem
inauthentic that just seems like
we can get ourselves into inauthentic
patterns
by uh falling into habits that aren't
uh good for us and there's different
ways we try to break our habits through
trying new activities uh going to talk
therapy and so on
and the controlled use of these drugs
under certain kinds of situations is
another way in which we can
break our habits and then we can decide
what new habits we want to lay down
i certainly think the first area that
i'm
like prepare i will be prepared to
secede ground on
is going to be single time experiences
that force a reflective period
afterwards
i think i have a particular issue with
i'm not just saying just man up like
your heartbreak is is easy like no it
sucks
but jumping on a course of ssris to
essentially nerf all of the edges of
your experience
i was thinking of while i was reading
the book remember that surrogates film
with bruce willis do you ever watch that
i didn't see it no
okay so it's kind of like um future
world
and all of the humans now just exist in
these lush apartments
in in pods and they have surrogates like
androids that run around
on their behalf and they never get cold
and they never get hungry and they never
get whatever and they're just filled
with tubes and they're essentially just
asleep the whole time
and i was like think about what most
personal development
strategies are doing at the moment
they're actually reconnecting us
with kind of a much more ancestral
paleolithic experience why people doing
cold showers
and breath work in high intensity
interval training like what are all of
the reasons for these things it's
because it puts you into a state of
discomfort
in a world which is constantly trying to
make you more and more comfortable
you can amazon prime a tv on which to
watch
netflix the best films on the planet for
less than like the price of a cocktail
per month
while you deliver a five-star michelin
chef
steak to your door without even having
to leave your house like
these are the antidotes to the ailments
of modern society
earlier on you mentioned about an
analogy to basically like the minimalist
movement
you know like if you were to think about
the cynics like diogenes
from ancient times going back to you
know like greece
and think about what they were doing
even that was look i will strip away all
of the
extraneous [ __ ] that i don't need i
don't even need this pot
when alexander the great comes i'll just
tell him that you stood in my sunlight
like all of these sort of stories right
like what are we doing with that and
um again my concern is that by
increasing the ability for people to
take advantage of a very very convenient
world
i wonder where we lose our humanity
along the way where do we actually kind
of drop that off
and the examples you've given that have
been
like awkwardly robust at sort of dealing
with the criticisms i had
uh of those i find the most compelling
definitely
go do something because i i would say to
nobody don't go and do a 10-day
meditation retreat but 10-day meditation
retreat
and a single time mild mdma dose are
probably not going to have
much too dissimilar experiences you're
going to break down a ton
of different thinking habits you're
going to come out an entirely new person
you're not going to think in the same
sort of patterns anymore
but for one i would be like yes get
yourself away like
go go and enjoy the north west of
england or whatever at this retreat
and then the other one for some reason
i'm a bit like oh
yeah but what about this the sacred soul
and the the ethereal
you know like the untouched relationship
you know
so those things are in some ways i think
artificially separated because
you know the use of psychoactive
substances for religious and spiritual
development is something that goes back
thousands of years within our species i
mean there's even some scholarship now
coming out suggesting that
some of the early founding of religious
movements were probably
uh partly set off by people who were
having drug i've got this book
i've got the the what's it called the
immortality key
um the immortality literally literally
got delivered today
i've got him i've got him coming on in
in january i'm excited i can't pronounce
his surname i'm sorry man i think your
surname is going to take me a couple of
months to prepare to say
yeah i mean i think there these kind of
um
these movements have been trying to
strive for kind of authenticity where we
aren't
so bogged down by the patterns of the
world you know
are our uh you know
imagined hierarchies and our our
in-group out-group distinctions and all
this kind of stuff you know there's lots
of
religious and wisdom and spiritual
movements that try to get people to
break down some of that stuff and they
do it through different
techniques uh meditation is one such
technique exercise
for some people is a way of just you
know getting their mind in a certain
kind of different space
and also the use of you know like
ayahuasca and the amazon basin has been
going on for thousands of years peyote
in the native american church
um you know lsd has only been around so
long because it was synthesized in a lab
but it's the same kind of an idea it's
just using a substance that
prompts your mind to enter into a
a space whereby
many people feel that they are able to
clear away the
dross and the confusion and the clutter
and the socialization
and the distinctions and the stereotypes
and get down
to the basic fact of the matter and kind
of rebuild their perception from there
and so you know this is if you think of
it as one of a number of tools that
human societies over millennia have
developed uh including contemplative
practices and so forth to try to get
down to the bare bones then
then you see it as really part of that
same tradition that you're keyed into
rather than something that's competing
with it
i think you're right man i think you're
right look love is the drug
will be linked in the show notes below
the chemical future of our relationships
if you bite through that link you will
be supporting the show at no extra cost
to yourself of course
brian if people want to check out more
of your work or any other stuff where
should they go
uh all my writing academic writing is on
academia.edu
my name uh brian d erp i think it is i'm
on twitter
i'm on researchgate and you can reach
out to me in any of those places
sick thank you man yeah thanks for this
conversation this is great
you